It's only getting every customer's order right. It's only a point-of-sale system connected by Spectrum fiber-powered business internet, helping you track hundreds of secure transactions. And it's all backed by 24-7 U.S.-based customer support and local technicians. It's only everything. Get business internet advantage free, forever, when you get four mobile lines from Spectrum. Visit Spectrum.com slash free-for-life to find out how. Restrictions apply.
这仅仅是确保每一位顾客的订单准确无误。这仅仅是一个由Spectrum光纤商业互联网连接的销售点系统，帮助您追踪数百笔安全交易。这一切都有全天候美国本土客户支持和当地技术人员作为后盾。这仅仅是一切。当您从Spectrum购买四条移动线路时，即可免费获得商业互联网优势，终身有效。访问Spectrum.com斜杠free-for-life了解详情。受限制条款约束。
Service is not available in all areas. This summer, many Americans are hands. heading back to the office, trading sweatpants and shorts for button pants and business casual, hopping into their cars or onto the subway, and seeing coworkers after more than a year of working from home. But even as companies reopen their long-shuttered offices, fault lines are emerging between some company's expectations and their employee's desires. In mid-June, for example, the CEO of the Investment Bank, Morgan Stanley, said that he expects his workers to be back in their New York offices by September. But a May Gallup poll found that
并非所有地区都提供此服务。今年夏天，许多美国人正准备重返办公室，脱下运动裤和短裤，换上衬衫和商务休闲装，跳进汽车或挤上地铁，在居家办公一年多后再次见到同事。但即使公司重新开放了长期关闭的办公室，公司期望与员工意愿之间也出现了分歧。例如，在6月中旬，投资银行摩根士丹利的首席执行官表示，他希望员工在9月前回到纽约办公室。但5月份的一项盖洛普民意调查发现，
35% of all full-time employees in the U.S. would prefer to keep working remotely. In some fields, including finance and consulting, that percentage is more than half. So what happens next? How will our workplaces change? And how will we as employees or employers adapt? What will the new normal look like? How can both workers and companies thrive in what promises to be a new world of remote and hybrid work? What are the advantages and the potential pitfalls of a permanently remote or a hybrid workforce. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Sedal Neely, a professor of business administration at the Harvard
35%的美国全职员工更愿意继续远程办公。在金融和咨询等一些领域，这一比例超过了一半。那么接下来会发生什么？我们的工作场所将如何改变？作为员工或雇主，我们将如何适应？新常态会是什么样子？在注定成为远程和混合办公的新世界中，员工和公司如何才能共同繁荣？永久远程或混合办公模式有哪些优势和潜在陷阱？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是哈佛商学院商业管理教授塞达尔·尼利博士。
Business School. She's been studying remote work since the 1990s, long before the COVID-19 pandemic forced many of us to turn our bedrooms or kitchens into home offices. Her book, Remote Work Revolution, succeeding from anywhere, published in March, offers lessons distilled from those decades of research on how employees, managers, and organizations can be productive and build a culture of trust and inclusivity, even when they're not located in the same physical space. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Neely. I'm so thrilled to be with you today. So as I just said, you've been studying remote work for many years. What was your reaction as you watched the mass transition to telework last year? Were you surprised by how quickly we managed to do it? I was stunned because for two decades, I did look at technology-enabled work,
她从20世纪90年代就开始研究远程办公，远在新冠疫情迫使我们许多人将卧室或厨房变成家庭办公室之前。她的书《远程办公革命：从任何地方取得成功》于3月出版，书中提炼了她数十年的研究成果，探讨了员工、管理者和组织如何在不在同一物理空间的情况下，保持高效并建立信任和包容的文化。感谢您今天加入我们，尼利博士。我很高兴今天能与您在一起。正如我刚才所说，您研究远程办公已经很多年了。当您看到去年大规模向远程办公转型时，您的反应是什么？我们如此迅速地完成这一转型，您感到惊讶吗？我感到震惊，因为二十年来，我确实研究过技术支持的工作、
global work, remote work, virtual work, but it was always 25, 30 percent of organizations that participated in any kind of virtuality sometimes because they were globally distributed. And the adoption of many of the digital tools that people picked up in like days have always been a source of frustration for companies. We have all these tools. People don't adopt them. So to see people having to use them and for the technologies to become lifelines within days across industries was extraordinary. Never in my lifetime did I think that we would see such scale or magnitude, but we did it. What changed since you first started studying remote work that made the transition go so smoothly?
全球工作、远程工作、虚拟工作，但参与任何形式虚拟化工作的组织总是只有25%到30%，有时是因为它们是全球分布的。人们在几天内就上手使用的许多数字工具，一直以来都是公司感到沮丧的根源。我们有这么多工具，但人们就是不用。所以，看到人们不得不使用它们，并且这些技术在几天之内就成为了各行各业的生命线，这真是非同寻常。我一生中从未想过我们会看到如此规模或程度的转变，但我们做到了。自您开始研究远程办公以来，有什么变化使得这次转型如此顺利？
It's not anything related to the technology, is the necessity. Listen, we were in the middle of a global pandemic, a contagious virus, a deadly contagious virus. So we knew, organizations, institutions knew, that the only thing to do is to go into our homes for the sake of safety, but we also needed to continue working.
这与技术无关，而是出于必要。听着，我们正处于全球大流行之中，一种传染性病毒，一种致命的传染性病毒。所以我们知道，组织和机构都知道，唯一能做的就是为了安全回到家中，但我们也需要继续工作。
So the necessity motivated individuals, teams and organizations to use these digital tools, it was a no-choice matter, right? And the thing that's been surprising to most people that I've talked to over the last 15 months or so is how at the end of the day, easy it was to use all of these digital tools, to communicate with others, that it was actually doable. Now, no one would say that remote work was easy, and it's no panacea, but it was doable and it helped all of us with our continuity. As I mentioned in my introduction, there are some mismatched expectations emerging now between employers who want people back in the office and employees who want to stay remote or work on a hybrid schedule. How do you expect this to shake out and who's going to? to have the bigger challenge to adapt? Do we ever? So here you have, the numbers are staggering. 81% according to Harvard Business School online survey wants to retain some kind of remote or virtual work in their repertoire. The Gardner Group would cite 87%. And you said that according to your
因此，这种必要性促使个人、团队和组织使用这些数字工具，这没得选，对吧？在过去15个月左右的时间里，我交谈过的大多数人感到惊讶的是，归根结底，使用所有这些数字工具与他人交流是多么容易，这实际上是可行的。当然，没有人会说远程办公很容易，它也不是万灵药，但它是可行的，它帮助我们所有人保持了工作的连续性。正如我在介绍中提到的，现在雇主希望员工回到办公室，而员工希望保持远程或混合办公，双方的期望出现了错位。您认为这会如何收场？谁将面临更大的适应挑战？我们会有吗？你看，这些数字令人震惊。根据哈佛商学院在线调查，81%的人希望在他们的工作方式中保留某种远程或虚拟办公。高德纳咨询公司引用的是87%。而您说根据您的
Gallup poll, which is consistent with all of the surveys and polls that have been, gathered over the last few months, up to 35% want to do it full time. Companies, on the other hand, to the tune of 68 or 70%, depending on which survey you look at, would want people back in person full time. And this is the tension and this is the dilemma. And what we're seeing is that companies are being forced to contemplate the mix of virtual, non-virtual, remote, non-remote, some call it hybrid, some call it dynamic. but to contemplate new work arrangements because I do believe that in this time, in this time in history, employees have the power.
盖洛普民意调查，这与过去几个月收集的所有调查和民调结果一致，高达35%的人希望全职远程办公。另一方面，根据您查看的调查，68%到70%的公司希望员工全职回到办公室。这就是紧张局势，这就是困境。我们看到的是，公司被迫考虑虚拟、非虚拟、远程、非远程的组合，有些人称之为混合办公，有些人称之为动态办公，但必须考虑新的工作安排，因为我相信，在历史的这个时刻，员工拥有权力。
Wow, that's good to know as an employee. One of the worries expressed, and I think you've alluded to this by some leaders, is that remote work will erode office culture. I think that's part of why a lot of companies want people back. Here in Washington, D.C., for example, the CEO of Washingtonian magazine wrote an op-ed arguing that up to 20% of employees' time in the office is spent doing things like helping a colleague, mentoring more junior people, celebrating someone's birthday. These are the things that make up office culture. But she even suggested that people who don't want to come back to the office will be easier to fire because they won't be doing those things. And that got a lot of people at the magazine pretty annoyed, and they went on strike for a day. How valid are these concerns? Does remote work change office culture? And if so, is that really a bad thing? You know, it's interesting because she also had to write an apology, right? Please come back. I'm so sorry. Going back to the point of who has influence and power at this point, she needed them. So she apologized. Oh, oh, I'm so sorry. And come back, please. Here's the thing. What I've been saying,
哇，作为员工，这真是个好消息。一些领导者表达的担忧之一，我想您也提到过，是远程办公会侵蚀办公室文化。我认为这就是许多公司希望员工回来的部分原因。例如，在华盛顿特区，《华盛顿人》杂志的首席执行官写了一篇专栏文章，认为员工在办公室里高达20%的时间花在帮助同事、指导初级员工、庆祝生日等事情上。这些就是构成办公室文化的东西。但她甚至暗示，那些不想回到办公室的人更容易被解雇，因为他们不会做这些事情。这让杂志社的许多人感到非常恼火，他们罢工了一天。这些担忧有多大依据？远程办公会改变办公室文化吗？如果是这样，这真的是一件坏事吗？你知道，这很有趣，因为她后来也不得不写道歉信，对吧？请回来。我很抱歉。回到目前谁拥有影响力和权力的问题上，她需要他们。所以她道歉了。哦，哦，我很抱歉。请回来。事情是这样的。我一直在说，
for several months now, and I still feel the same way about this, is that the cultures of our organizations, as we've known them, have shifted and changed. Remote Works presence, starting about March 2020, has changed how people work together, how people communicate, how people solve problems. What is culture after all? Culture is defined as what are our shared values, which means what's important to us. That's typically fixed and unchanged unless we're growing along those dimensions. We're augmenting our shared values. But the other part of culture is what are our shared norms, the attitudes, the behaviors that we espouse in order to get work done? People talk about cultures, how work gets done. Now, there's no doubt
几个月来，我对此仍然有同样的感觉，那就是我们所知的组织文化已经发生了转变和改变。从2020年3月左右开始，远程办公的存在改变了人们共同工作的方式、沟通的方式以及解决问题的方式。毕竟什么是文化？文化被定义为我们的共同价值观，这意味着什么对我们很重要。除非我们在这些维度上成长，否则这通常是固定不变的。我们正在增强我们的共同价值观。但文化的另一部分是我们的共同规范，即我们为了完成工作而推崇的态度和行为。人们谈论文化，即工作是如何完成的。现在，毫无疑问，
that how we've been getting work done since the pandemic hit has shifted. We don't have people down the hall any longer. So we create opportunities, structured, unstructured opportunities to mentor. We've been onboarding virtually, which is a thing. A very effective virtual onboarding practice can set people up for success in their organizations. We've been collaborating, innovating, creating, solving problems, and bringing value to our stakeholders and shareholders in our virtual environment. So to believe that the only way that this can happen is through in-person is a mistake, to believe that we're still the same people of 2019 who want that same life and that same kind of commute and office culture is a mistake. It's about how do we now
自疫情爆发以来，我们完成工作的方式已经发生了转变。我们不再有同事在走廊对面了。所以我们创造了机会，结构化的、非结构化的指导机会。我们一直在进行虚拟入职，这确实是一回事。一种非常有效的虚拟入职实践可以为员工在组织中的成功奠定基础。我们一直在虚拟环境中协作、创新、创造、解决问题，并为我们的利益相关者和股东带来价值。因此，认为这只能通过面对面实现是一个错误，认为我们仍然是2019年的那群人，想要同样的生活、同样的通勤和办公室文化，也是一个错误。关键在于我们现在如何
take our changed individual needs and preferences and recreate and revise cultures that meet the moment. This is, I think, the fundamental question that organizations need to think about. Another thing that some companies and managers worry about is that they can't effectively monitor workers' productivity. You have a discussion in your book about companies that have tried using digital surveillance methods, such as monitoring keystrokes or requiring the cameras always be on, and how workers absolutely hate these methods. Are those worries about productivity valid and are there better ways to promote productivity? They're not valid.
利用我们改变了的个人需求和偏好，重新创造和修订适应当前时刻的文化。我认为，这是组织需要思考的根本问题。一些公司和管理者担心的另一件事是，他们无法有效地监控员工的生产力。您的书中讨论了那些尝试使用数字监控方法的公司，例如监控按键或要求始终开启摄像头，以及员工如何绝对讨厌这些方法。那些关于生产力的担忧有依据吗？是否有更好的方法来促进生产力？它们没有依据。
and what some call awareness technologies, the monitoring, like that's the kind of nice way of describing the surveillance systems. Not only do they not work, not only do employees hate them, they feel humiliated by them. That's the term that you hear, humiliated by them. And they also say, as soon as the economy improves, I am leaving this job. So there's no future in that.
有些人称之为意识技术，即监控，这是一种描述监控系统的委婉说法。它们不仅不起作用，不仅员工讨厌它们，他们还感到被羞辱。这就是你听到的那个词，被羞辱。他们还说，一旦经济好转，我就离开这份工作。所以这没有未来。
But in terms of productivity, there's 30 years of, research on the fact that productivity actually increases with remote work. It increases with remote work. It first started in 1993 by study conducted at Cisco, where they started to actually experiment with the hybrid work format. They didn't call it hybrid then, but that's exactly what it was. And they saw a rise in productivity. So other companies started to experiment as well. It's a micro system, later acquired by Oracle. in 1997, experimented with remote work and working from anywhere models as well. Not only did they see productivity shoot up, but they saw that they needed to make changes to their real estate holdings because of wanting to make things permanent.
但就生产力而言，有30年的研究表明，生产力实际上随着远程办公而提高。它随着远程办公而提高。它始于1993年思科进行的一项研究，当时他们开始尝试混合办公模式。他们当时不叫它混合办公，但那正是它的样子。他们看到了生产力的提高。所以其他公司也开始尝试。这是一个微系统，后来被甲骨文收购。1997年，他们也尝试了远程办公和从任何地方工作的模式。他们不仅看到生产力飙升，还看到由于希望将这些模式永久化，他们需要对房地产持有量进行调整。
So the fact is productivity increases not because people are plugging in more hours. It's because people value their autonomy, their flexibility, job satisfaction is higher in a flexible environment, and when job satisfaction is higher, people perform better. The bottom line here is when we are in a virtual hybrid or remote environment, we don't look at process and monitor for progress. We need to focus on outcomes after we equip people. So it's not about butts and seats. It's about outcomes, team cohesion, and helping to equip people to get there. So it sounds like some of what you're talking about is trust, trust in the employee. And I know you've spoken about two different types of trust that exist in workplaces,
事实是，生产力提高并不是因为人们投入了更多时间。这是因为人们重视他们的自主权和灵活性，在灵活的环境中工作满意度更高，而当工作满意度更高时，人们的表现就更好。这里的底线是，当我们处于虚拟、混合或远程环境中时，我们不看过程和监控进度。在装备好员工之后，我们需要关注结果。所以这与坐在座位上无关。这与结果、团队凝聚力以及帮助装备员工实现目标有关。所以听起来您谈论的部分内容是信任，对员工的信任。我知道您谈到过工作场所中存在的两种不同类型的信任，
the cognitive trust and emotional trust. Could you explain what you mean by those terms and how they're important to the effectiveness of workplaces, as well as to the workplace culture. Trust is at the heart of everything related to the future of work. And the first thing is the cognitive trust, sometimes called cognitive swift trust, is a type of trust that's been identified to be incredibly effective when people are not co-located. And it's grounded in the understanding that collaborators have the competence, meaning they're qualified to do this work that we're engaged in together, and that they're also dependable.
认知信任和情感信任。您能解释一下这些术语的含义，以及它们对工作场所的有效性以及工作场所文化的重要性吗？信任是与未来工作相关的一切的核心。首先是认知信任，有时被称为认知快速信任，这是一种在人们不在一起工作时被证明非常有效的信任类型。它基于这样一种理解，即合作者具备能力，意味着他们有资格完成我们共同从事的这项工作，而且他们也是可靠的。
The two things that are absolutely knowable. They're observable. They're knowable. You can get references around those. And once you understand that, the idea is you confer trust right away. You give trust by understanding those two things, reliable and qualified. The second type of trust, emotional trust, takes longer to achieve, but emotional trust is grounded in the understanding and the belief that people care about you, that they care about your interest, that they care about your difficulties, that your concerns are their concerns, they care about your aspirations. And the way to develop that is it's actually quite simple, is to be able to have
这两件事是绝对可知的。它们是可观察的。它们是可知的。你可以围绕这些获得参考。一旦你理解了这一点，想法就是你立即给予信任。通过理解这两点，即可靠和合格，你给予信任。第二种类型的信任，情感信任，需要更长的时间才能实现，但情感信任基于这样一种理解和信念，即人们关心你，他们关心你的利益，他们关心你的困难，你的担忧就是他们的担忧，他们关心你的抱负。实现这一点的途径其实很简单，就是能够进行
mutual self-disclosure, people sharing of themselves. And, you know, psychologists have shown that when we exercise self-disclosure, people find us more likable and approachable. Go figure, Kim. So if you disclose more, people will say, oh, this person is approachable and likable. But the second part is also critically important. It's about empathy. Not only empathy, being able to see the perspective of others or be in the shoes of others, but also reflect it back to people through your words and deeds. So if people feel you care about them and if people feel that you understand them, emotional trust emerges.
相互的自我披露，人们分享他们自己。而且，你知道，心理学家已经证明，当我们进行自我披露时，人们会觉得我们更可爱、更容易接近。想一想，金。所以如果你披露得更多，人们会说，哦，这个人很容易接近，很可爱。但第二部分也至关重要。那就是同理心。不仅是同理心，能够站在他人的角度或设身处地为他人着想，还要通过你的言行将其反映给人们。所以如果人们觉得你关心他们，如果人们觉得你理解他们，情感信任就会产生。
Leaders must earn emotional trust in a remote environment. There's no choice about this. So are we building emotional trust by basically, bringing our coworkers into our homes? I mean, when I'm zooming with people, I see their artwork, sometimes their kids come into the room, or they've got a dog in their lap. But it's very, very human in a way that I would never have known these people. Is that, are we building emotional trust that way? Absolutely. Isn't that self-disclosure when people get to see a glimpse of our lives through video. When we bring people into our homes, they see our pets, they see our children,
领导者必须在远程环境中赢得情感信任。对此别无选择。那么，我们是否通过基本上把同事带进我们的家里来建立情感信任呢？我的意思是，当我和人们进行Zoom会议时，我看到他们的艺术品，有时他们的孩子走进房间，或者他们的膝盖上有一只狗。但这以一种我永远不会了解这些人的方式变得非常、非常人性化。是这样吗，我们正在通过这种方式建立情感信任吗？绝对是。当人们通过视频看到我们生活的一瞥时，这难道不是自我披露吗？当我们把人们带进我们的家里，他们看到我们的宠物，他们看到我们的孩子，
which has happened to me, big meeting, super, super intense, big decision meeting. My eight-year-old child passes me a note completely visible on video and says, on this note, I look at this note, you know, you want to know, it's an emergency, let me look, and it says, we're out of fruits, can I have a cookie? was so surprised that he showed up that I told the people that I was meeting with, I said, I just have a note here to share with everyone. We laughed and laughed and laughed. But it was a bonding moment, right, when Daniel showed up in that way. But here's the thing. Theodore Roosevelt famously said that people don't care how much you know until they know how much
这发生在我身上，大型会议，超级、超级紧张，重大决策会议。我八岁的孩子递给我一张纸条，在视频中完全可见，上面写着，我看着这张纸条，你知道，你想知道，这是紧急情况，让我看看，上面写着，我们没有水果了，我可以吃块饼干吗？我太惊讶他出现了，以至于我告诉和我开会的人，我说，我这里有一张纸条要和大家分享。我们笑啊笑啊笑。但这是一个建立联系的时刻，对吧，当丹尼尔以那种方式出现时。但事情是这样的。西奥多·罗斯福曾有名言说，在人们知道你有多关心他们之前，他们不在乎你知道多少。
you care. And this is what emotional trust is about. caring and demonstrating that you care. And that's what you need to do in a remote environment. Are there extra challenges to remote work for new employees, whether we're talking about young people who are just starting their professional lives or even more experienced workers who are starting new jobs? And what can companies do to make these transitions go more smoothly? Yes, indeed.
这就是情感信任的意义所在。关心并展示你关心。这就是你在远程环境中需要做的。对于新员工来说，远程办公是否有额外的挑战，无论是刚开始职业生涯的年轻人，还是开始新工作的更有经验的员工？公司可以做些什么来使这些过渡更顺利？是的，确实如此。
I do think that an all-remote format or arrangement can be challenged, for new entrants in an organization if we are not deliberate and intentional on how we are bringing them into the fold. It's like how do we bring the core despise into their hearts? How do we make sure that they are meeting the right people across the organization, not just the team or the group that they'll be working with, but you have to facilitate their meeting and connection with others across the organization, provide lists, pair people up, with onboarding buddies where they can go and ask questions that they may not feel comfortable just asking anyone. Having them learn with others. They're all of these methods, which is all
我确实认为，如果我们不审慎和刻意地考虑如何将他们纳入其中，全远程模式或安排对组织的新进入者来说可能是一个挑战。这就像我们如何将核心精神带入他们的心中？我们如何确保他们正在结识组织中合适的人，而不仅仅是他们将要共事的团队或小组，你必须促进他们与组织中其他人的会面和联系，提供名单，将人们配对，与入职伙伴一起，他们可以在那里提出他们可能觉得不舒服直接问任何人的问题。让他们与他人一起学习。所有这些方法，都是
about deliberately opening up the organization so people can feel like they have actual contacts that they feel connected and a lot of learning. So one example, one company that just does this magnificently well, they actually make sure that for the first three weeks when someone joins, that they're never spending a day alone. They're always connected in some kind of activity, whether it's learning, meeting, attending, observing virtual lunches, virtual tea with others. So very quickly, people feel, ah, I feel like I'm part of this. That's a great plan. But let's talk a little more about the hybrid office. Many companies right now are not planning to go fully remote, but they're considering allowing employees more freedom to telework part-time, which, of course,
关于刻意开放组织，这样人们就可以感觉到他们有实际的联系，他们感到连接，并且有很多学习。所以一个例子，一家公司做得非常出色，他们实际上确保在某人加入的前三周，他们从不独自度过一天。他们总是参与某种活动，无论是学习、开会、参加、观察虚拟午餐、与他人的虚拟茶会。所以很快，人们就会觉得，啊，我觉得我是其中的一部分。这是一个很棒的计划。但让我们多谈谈混合办公室。目前许多公司并不打算完全远程，但他们正在考虑允许员工更多地远程办公的自由，这当然，
has challenges. How will meetings that have been on Zoom or teams for the past year plus, how is that going to work when some employees are in the office and some employees are home? I think the concerns around how are we going to ever engage with one another, effectively, if not everyone is in the same place. You know, all or nothing is easy. We're all on Zoom or we're all in person. It's the mix that makes people nervous. So let me be the first to say that this kind of mix is normal in global environments where geographical distribution is by definition part of how people work, right? Global teams, global collaborators are not in the same place. But the picture of this is, you might have some people in the same room.
有挑战。过去一年多一直在Zoom或Teams上进行的会议，当一些员工在办公室而一些员工在家时，这会如何运作？我认为围绕如果我们不都在同一个地方，我们将如何有效地与彼此互动的问题，存在担忧。你知道，要么全有要么全无很容易。我们都在Zoom上，或者我们都在面对面。正是这种混合让人们感到紧张。所以让我先说，这种混合在全球环境中是正常的，地理分布本身就是人们工作方式的一部分，对吧？全球团队、全球合作者不在同一个地方。但这种情况的画面是，你可能在同一个房间里有一些人。
You need the digital tools and technologies, whether it's individuals bringing their laptops into the space, if they all have one. If not, you're going to need large monitors so that those who are on Zoom or Microsoft Teams, whatever method that they're using, can be visible. And so whether you're in the room or you're not in the room, the onus is on the leader to ensure,
你需要数字工具和技术，无论是个人将笔记本电脑带入空间，如果他们都有的话。如果没有，你需要大型显示器，以便那些使用Zoom或Microsoft Teams，无论他们使用什么方法的人，都能被看到。所以无论你是在房间里还是不在房间里，领导者的责任是确保，
sure that there's inclusive, equitable communication among all the members of that group. The leader also has to set norms. Now that we're working in this way, you know, in my book I talk about relaunches, launches and relaunches, you have to explicitly have a conversation of how are we going to communicate with one another, given the fact that this is our new structure. So let's ensure that everyone has the opportunity to contribute. How do we make sure that happens? No one dominates.
确保该小组的所有成员之间有包容、公平的沟通。领导者还必须设定规范。现在我们以这种方式工作，你知道，在我的书中我谈到了重新启动、启动和重新启动，你必须明确地进行关于鉴于这是我们的新结构，我们将如何与彼此沟通的对话。所以让我们确保每个人都有机会做出贡献。我们如何确保这一点发生？没有人占主导地位。
Those who are in person are not going to be privileged more than others. You have to have rules of engagement. And once you do, you'd be surprised how well it works. The other thing that's really important to keep in mind, back to the leadership question, is leaders cannot unwittingly start having watercula conversations with those who are there in person that, you know, maybe provides information, quick bonding, et cetera.
那些面对面的人不会比其他人享有更多特权。你必须有参与规则。一旦你这样做了，你会惊讶地发现它运作得有多好。另一件非常重要的事情要记住，回到领导力问题，领导者不能在无意中开始与那些面对面的人进行饮水机谈话，你知道，也许提供信息、快速建立联系等等。
Leaders have to be very careful about that. That because people are not there in person doesn't mean that they don't deserve the casual interactive type of moments with them. So they have to ensure that they're doing the same things with those who are not in the room, even if it's at a later time. One of the interesting things about working using Zoom is that everyone can't talk at once, right? Only one person can be heard. And that's been very difficult, I think, for a lot of people who think that they have a lot to say.
领导者必须对此非常小心。因为人们不在现场并不意味着他们不值得与他们进行随意的互动时刻。所以他们必须确保他们对那些不在房间里的人做同样的事情，即使是在稍后的时间。关于使用Zoom工作的一个有趣的事情是，每个人不能同时说话，对吧？只有一个人能被听到。我认为这对很多认为自己有很多话要说的人来说非常困难。
Indeed, indeed, that raising hand function, huh? But, you know, many people. Back in school, back in school, back in school. Many people say that the video conferencing modality has been democratizing for some people, particularly people who had felt marginalized or not enough opportunity to speak in the past, people have felt like they've had more opportunities in this type of environment. So for me, the lessons that we've gained over the last 15 months, whether we're in person or not, we should carry forward, give everyone voice, give everyone an opportunity to contribute.
确实，确实，那个举手功能，嗯？但是，你知道，许多人。回到学校，回到学校，回到学校。许多人说，视频会议模式对一些人来说是民主化的，特别是那些过去感到被边缘化或没有足够机会发言的人，人们觉得在这种类型的环境中他们有更多的机会。所以对我来说，我们在过去15个月里获得的经验教训，无论我们是否面对面，我们都应该发扬光大，给每个人发言权，给每个人做出贡献的机会。
So it's been a lot of discussion over the course of the pandemic, the idea of Zoom fatigue. And one thing that you discuss in your book is the importance of choosing the right digital tools when you're working remotely. So not everything needs to be a video call. Can you talk about that? I mean, what are the differences between synchronous and asynchronous and rich and lean communication tools? Absolutely. You've read the book, Kim. I love this.
所以在疫情期间有很多讨论，关于Zoom疲劳的想法。你在书中讨论的一件事是，当你远程工作时选择正确的数字工具的重要性。所以并不是每件事都需要视频通话。你能谈谈那个吗？我的意思是，同步和异步以及丰富和精简的沟通工具之间有什么区别？绝对是。你读过这本书，金。我喜欢这个。
This is like amazing. Listen, I am firmly convinced that tech exhaustion should not exist. People call it Zoom fatigue, but since the CEO of Zoom has endorsed my book, I no longer use that term. But no, the tech exhaustion occurs when we over index on certain communication tools that are video or, We schedule meetings edge to edge just because we can. We absolutely should not. And then on top of that, we have video calls when, in fact, we should be sending a simple email. So the rich versus lean media and asynchronous and synchronous media are various ways to categorize technology, the features of technology.
这太棒了。听着，我坚信技术消耗不应该存在。人们称之为Zoom疲劳，但由于Zoom的首席执行官认可了我的书，我不再使用那个术语。但不，技术消耗发生在我们过度索引某些视频沟通工具时，或者，我们仅仅因为我们可以就安排背靠背的会议。我们绝对不应该这样做。然后除此之外，我们进行视频通话，而实际上，我们应该发送一封简单的电子邮件。所以丰富媒体与精简媒体以及异步和同步媒体是分类技术、技术特征的各种方式。
So lean media is something like email or Google Doc. where you don't get context, you don't get nonverbal cues, it's text, it's rapid, different than a video conference where you do get context, you do get nonverbal cues, but you don't always need those. Sometimes lean is exactly what you want. The synchronous asynchronous speaks to real-time live versus delayed. On many occasions, for example, if you need to process complex information, as a group. The worst thing you can do is get on a video call to talk about complex information that needs to be processed, digested. The most efficient thing to do is you send it through some kind of lean medium and then perhaps talk about it in the end. So there's so many
所以精简媒体就像电子邮件或Google文档。在那里你得不到背景，你得不到非语言暗示，它是文本，它是快速的，与视频会议不同，在那里你确实得到背景，你确实得到非语言暗示，但你并不总是需要那些。有时精简正是你想要的。同步异步指的是实时直播与延迟。在许多情况下，例如，如果你需要作为一个小组处理复杂信息。你能做的最糟糕的事情就是进行视频通话来谈论需要处理、消化复杂信息。最有效的方法是你通过某种精简媒体发送它，然后也许最后谈论它。所以有这么多
efficiencies that we're losing because we tend to choose technologies that are easiest for or based on our preferences. Some people say, but I love seeing people and I love video. It's like, actually, you may love video. There's also a lot of data that suggest that certain people in certain cultures and geographies have very different preferences. So it's not just about you. It's about how effective you want to be.
效率我们正在失去，因为我们倾向于选择最容易或基于我们偏好的技术。有些人说，但我喜欢看到人们，我喜欢视频。就像，实际上，你可能喜欢视频。还有很多数据表明，某些文化和地理位置的某些人有非常不同的偏好。所以这不仅仅是关于你。这是关于你想变得多有效。
And to mix it up, you have to mix it up. We've been talking about. remote work as if it's universal, but of course it's not. Many jobs have to be done in person. And some economists and political scientists have written that remote work is going to contribute to the already dire problem of inequality because financial and work-life benefits of telework go mostly to high-income office workers. Do you worry about that aspect of remote work? And is there anything that we can do to compensate for this? I do worry about this a great deal. Part of the reason I worry about it is sometimes we look at work or tasks or job roles and
而且要混合起来，你必须混合起来。我们一直在谈论。远程工作好像它是普遍的，但当然它不是。许多工作必须面对面完成。一些经济学家和政治学家写道，远程工作将加剧已经可怕的不平等问题，因为远程办公的财务和工作生活福利主要流向高收入办公室工作人员。你担心远程工作的那个方面吗？我们有什么办法可以补偿这一点吗？我非常担心这一点。我担心的部分原因是，有时我们看工作或任务或工作角色，
immediately say, well, this person's job or this person can be a remote worker or that person needs to be what they call onsite essential people. The reality is if we are redesigning our environment to be more hybrid. and to give people more flexibility so that they have some at-home work days, we need to have a system-level view at what we need to get done in an environment. And what I mean by that is not categorize individuals as on-site versus remote people, but look at the work and how we can distribute the work so that we can give people the opportunity to have flexible work. I'll give you an example of this.
立即说，好吧，这个人的工作或这个人可以是一个远程工作者，或者那个人需要成为他们所说的现场必要人员。现实情况是，如果我们正在重新设计我们的环境以更加混合。并给人们更多的灵活性，以便他们有一些在家工作的日子，我们需要有一个系统层面的视角来看我们需要在一个环境中完成什么。我的意思是，不要将个人分类为现场人员与远程人员，而是看工作以及我们如何分配工作，以便我们可以给人们机会进行灵活的工作。我给你举个例子。
So say you have six to seven people that have to be on-site essential people because either they're attached to major servers in your organization, mainframe rooms, et cetera, that they need to control rooms, rather, that they need to make sure work well. the question is, how can we think about the six people and say, well, we actually need to be pooling and rotating so that three people can come on site and the other three can work from home on these different things. We have to be thoughtful and creative to first of all understand what can be done remotely or not. The second thing is there is no doubt that there will be people who will need to be on site. And that's where we need to share the privileges and the rewards that flexibility can offer with them. And smart companies do things like give people 10 learning days that they can do remotely.
所以假设你有六到七个人必须是现场必要人员，因为要么他们连接到你组织中的主要服务器、主机房等，他们需要控制室，而是，他们需要确保工作良好。问题是，我们如何思考这六个人并说，好吧，我们实际上需要进行汇集和轮换，以便三个人可以到现场，另外三个人可以在这些不同的事情上在家工作。我们必须深思熟虑和有创造力，首先要了解什么可以远程完成或不能。第二件事是，毫无疑问，将会有需要到现场的人。这就是我们需要与他们分享灵活性可以提供的特权和奖励的地方。聪明的公司会做一些事情，比如给人们10个他们可以远程完成的学习日。
They can use however they want, once a week, you know, two consecutive weeks. But give people some of the privileges that people are experiencing and a little bit can go a very long way. So I think we need to be creative. We need to rethink how we pool and rotate. and we need to be very honest about what are the things that we can do from home or not. So I'll just pause there. You were working on your book Remote Work Revolution for several years before the pandemic. And also you've been studying this whole concept for a couple of decades, as we said.
他们可以随心所欲地使用，每周一次，你知道，连续两周。但给人们一些人们正在经历的特权，一点点可以走很长的路。所以我认为我们需要有创造力。我们需要重新思考我们如何汇集和轮换。我们需要非常诚实地对待我们可以在家做什么或不能做什么。所以我只是暂停在那里。你在疫情前几年一直在写你的书《远程办公革命》。而且正如我们所说，你已经研究这个整个概念几十年了。
What got you interested in this topic to begin with? I was convinced in the late 90s that technology was going to completely change how we worked. I am someone who loves technology. I am myself a social scientist, but at the center of everything that I've ever done, I've believed that technology would reshape how people connected, interacted, how we expanded our markets. And this belief is what led me to go into a PhD program. that looked at the intersection of work technology and organizations.
是什么让你一开始就对这个话题感兴趣？我在90年代末确信技术将彻底改变我们的工作方式。我是一个热爱技术的人。我自己是一名社会科学家，但在我所做的一切的核心，我相信技术将重塑人们连接、互动的方式，我们如何扩大我们的市场。这种信念是我进入博士课程的原因。研究工作技术和组织交叉点。
And what I didn't anticipate is that it would unfold in the way that it did. I believe that COVID has accelerated the virtualization of work by a decade or more, maybe even 20 years. But I was always convinced of this. And so my work always looked at the business practices, at the top level all the way down to the micro, the everyday work activities that would be shaped by global economy, that would be shaped by digital transformation. And I believe that this accelerated pace that we are in now
而我没有预料到的是，它会以那种方式展开。我相信新冠疫情将工作的虚拟化加速了十年或更长时间，甚至可能是20年。但我一直确信这一点。所以我的工作总是着眼于商业实践，从最高层一直到微观，即将被全球经济塑造、将被数字转型塑造的日常工作活动。我相信我们现在所处的这种加速步伐
is only beginning. So did what you observed over the last year change the book? You were in the middle of writing it, correct? and here the pandemic hit. Was there anything that surprised you, and then you had to sort of rip up a whole chapter and start again? You know, it's interesting.
才刚刚开始。那么你在过去一年观察到的东西改变了这本书吗？你当时正在写它，对吧？疫情爆发了。有什么让你惊讶的事情吗，然后你不得不撕掉整章并重新开始？你知道，这很有趣。
The book ultimately was designed around a set of questions that came up when I did a Q&A session with managers and leaders with Harvard Business Review. And interestingly enough, there were 15 top questions that everyone had. And so we wrote an HBR.org piece that the title was 15 questions answers about remote work. The moment that went live, I think we had something like half a million downloads in just a few days,
这本书最终是围绕我在与哈佛商业评论的经理和领导者进行问答环节时出现的一系列问题设计的。有趣的是，每个人都有15个热门问题。所以我们写了一篇HBR.org的文章，标题是关于远程工作的15个问题答案。那一刻上线时，我想我们在短短几天内就有大约五十万次下载，
which showed that this was not only what managers were worried about, but there was. an audience for this. So the book ultimately was organized around these key questions, around productivity, around trust, around digital tools, around the global framework that people need to think about. And so it was really informed by today, but I used all of the work of the last 50 years, 50 years, on virtuality and remote work to answer these questions in the book, one of the things that I would have loved to be able to do, but, you know, publishers say, you know, there are such things as word counts, is to try to think about how remote work might affect certain professions, whether it's teaching, whether it's sales. We do have a section in there. How do you do the emotional trust development in a sales context, right? It's not just within the organization, but outside the organization. I knew I had to add a piece there, but I would have loved to elaborate more on those things. But, you know, there's always future work.
这表明这不仅是经理们担心的问题，而且有。一个受众。所以这本书最终是围绕这些关键问题组织的，围绕生产力、信任、数字工具、人们需要思考的全球框架。所以它确实是由今天的信息所告知的，但我使用了过去50年、50年关于虚拟化和远程工作的全部工作来回答书中的这些问题，我本来很想做的一件事，但是，你知道，出版商说，你知道，有字数限制这样的事情，是尝试思考远程工作可能如何影响某些职业，无论是教学，还是销售。我们在那里有一个部分。你如何在销售环境中进行情感信任发展，对吧？这不仅是在组织内部，而且是在组织外部。我知道我必须在那里增加一个部分，但我本来很想详细阐述这些事情。但是，你知道，总有未来的工作。
Any advice, just to wrap up here, advice for workers and employers as we venture into this new world? Yes. The new term that I think captures all of the things that employees want is work life flexibility. The reason productivity goes up in remote work is because people can enjoy work life flexibility. We used to talk about work life balance as an aspiration for people that no one could ever achieve work life balance. And then we started to talk about work life tradeoffs where you lose in some places and you win in other places. You decide where you want to have your wins and losses. Today, we can talk about work-life flexibility by incorporating some remote work and people's professional arrangements.
最后，对工人和雇主有什么建议，当我们冒险进入这个新世界时？是的。我认为捕捉员工想要的所有东西的新术语是工作生活灵活性。远程工作中生产力提高的原因是因为人们可以享受工作生活灵活性。我们过去谈论工作生活平衡作为人们的愿望，没有人能实现工作生活平衡。然后我们开始谈论工作生活权衡，你在某些地方输了，在其他地方赢了。你决定你想在哪里有你的赢和输。今天，我们可以通过将一些远程工作和人们的专业安排结合起来，谈论工作生活灵活性。
And my deepest hope as we end our conversation today, Kim, is that people approach the future of work as leaders with courage and looking at their organizational needs and the needs and preferences of their employees rather than with the future. few years of the unknown. Remote work, hybrid work can be extremely effective so long as we set the right framework, equip people, and move forward with courage. Well, thank you for those wise words and for joining us today, Dr. Neely. It's been very interesting talking with you. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingofpsychology.org or on Apple Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts.
在我今天结束我们的谈话时，金，我最深切的希望是，人们作为领导者以勇气接近工作的未来，并着眼于他们的组织需求以及员工的需求和偏好，而不是以未来。几年的未知。远程工作、混合工作可以非常有效，只要我们设定正确的框架，装备人们，并以勇气前进。好吧，谢谢你的这些明智的话，也谢谢你今天加入我们，尼利博士。和你谈话非常有趣。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在www.combeatingofpsychology.org或Apple Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。
And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部一个词，在APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。对于美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。